>>> A SHOCKING MOMENT ON LIVE TV
WHEN A REPORTER IN WEST VIRGINIA
WAS HIT BY A CAR.
IT'S A MOMENT YOU HAVE TO SEE TO
BELIEVE.
>> AND NOW WE'RE STARTING TO
EXPERIENCE UNFORTUNATELY IN
FREEZE THAW WE SEE THIS, WATER
MAIN BREAKS.
>> I JUST GOT HIT BY A CAR, BUT
I'M OKAY.
I'M OKAY, TIM.
WE'RE ALL GOOD.
>> ARE YOU OKAY?
>> I'M OKAY.
YEAH, YOU KNOW THAT'S LIVE TV
FOR YOU.
IT'S ALL GOOD.
I ACTUALLY GOT HIT BY A CAR IN
COLLEGE TOO JUST LIKE THAT.
>> WOW.
>> I AM SO GLAD I'M OKAY.
YOU'RE OKAY.
WE'RE ALL GOOD.
>> SHE LATER SAID SHE WENT TO
THE HOSPITAL JUST TO GET CHECKED
OUT AND WAS OKAY, JUST SORE.
THE ANCHOR THERE TIM ERTZ, HE
COULDN'T REALLY SEE WHAT WAS
HAPPENING, JUST AUDIO IN HIS EAR
PIECE AND TOTAL CONFUSION.
HE ALSO SAID HE WAS VERY
GRATEFUL THAT SHE'S OKAY.
AND TORI JONES ME NOW.
YOU LIVED TO TELL THE TALE.
>> HELLO, THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME.
TELL US HOW YOU'RE DOING.
>> I APPRECIATE IT.
I'M DOING WELL.
I DID GO GET CHECKED OUT.
MY BOSS DROVE ME TO THE
HOSPITAL.
NOTHING BROKEN.
I'M ACTUALLY FEELING EVEN BETTER
TODAY THAN I WAS YESTERDAY AS
FAR AS SORENESS GOES.
IT'S ALL GOOD.
EVERYTHING IS GOING WELL.
I APPRECIATE YOU ASKING.
>> AND TAKE US THROUGH EXACTLY
WHAT HAPPENED AND WHAT WAS GOING
THROUGH YOUR MIND WHEN YOU WERE
SUDDENLY ON THE GROUND.
I SUPPOSE IT WAS ONE OF THOSE
THINGS, YOU KEPT BROADCASTING
WHICH, YOU KNOW, AS SOMEBODY WHO
USED TO BE IN LOCAL NEWS, A TIP
OF THE HAT TO YOU, YOU BEEN
BELIEVABLE JOB THERE MAINTAINING
YOUR COMPOSURE AND KEEPING THE
LIVE SHOT GOING, BUT I HAD TO
THINK, YOU KNOW, AFTER THE LIVE
SHOT WAS OVER THAT, YOU KNOW,
YOU WERE NOT FEELING VERY WELL.
>> THANK YOU.
YEAH, AFTER THE LIVE SHOT WAS
OVER, I THINK THAT'S WHEN
EVERYTHING DID KIND OF HIT ME,
NO PUN INTENDED, BUT DURING IT,
YOU KNOW, I WAS ASSIGNED TO DO A
WEATHER LIVE SHOT, AND I HAD
HEARD ABOUT A WATER MAIN BREAK
IN A TOWN OVER FROM CHARLESTON,
DUNBAR, WEST VIRGINIA, AND SO I
FIGURED, WELL, THAT'S A GOOD
ELEMENT FOR MY STORY TO GIVE
PEOPLE A VISUAL SINCE NOTHING
WAS REALLY HAPPENING.
THERE WAS SOME LIGHT RAIN, NO
ICE, NO SNOW.
SO NOTHING TO GET THE VIEWERS TO
SEE, THAT WAS COMING LATER ON IN
THE EVENING.
I FIGURED I WOULD GO THERE AND I
PARKED IN THE APARTMENT COMPLEX
RIGHT ON THE HILL AND I JUST SET
UP AND THEN AS I WAS GETTING
READY TO TALK, SHE CAME AND HIT
ME IN THE SIDE AND I DID KIND OF
BLANK OUT, BUT I DON'T KNOW, YOU
KNOW, I THINK I JUST WAS KIND OF
SHOCKED AND I DID AT ONE POINT
THINK I WAS GETTING KIND OF RUN
OVER, GOING UNDER HER TIRE.
IN THE END IT WAS FINE, AND I
KNEW INSTANTLY I WAS OKAY, SO
WHEN THE SHOCK AND ADRENALINE
KIND OF CAME OVER ME, I WAS KIND
OF IN THAT SPLIT SECOND, LET ME
GET UP AND TELL EVERYONE I'M
GOOD.
I'M OKAY.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T
UNDERSTAND IN LOCAL MARKETS, YOU
KNOW, REPORTERS LIKE YOURSELF,
YOU WERE DOING A PUBLIC SERVICE.
YOU'RE OUT THERE, YOU KNOW,
DOING A LIVE SHOT ON THE SIDE OF
THE ROAD, WHICH BY THE WAY, A
LOT OF, YOU KNOW, VETERANS IN
THE BUSINESS LIKE MYSELF, I JUST
GET SO WORRIED SICK WHEN I SEE
FOLKS LIKE YOURSELF STANDING
LIVE ON THE SIDE OF THE ROAD.
I HOPE TO GOD EVERYTHING IS
BEING DONE TO MAKE SURE YOU'RE
BEING TOTALLY SAFE, AND I KNOW
THE LOCAL REPORTERS ARE
OBVIOUSLY WISE ENOUGH TO DO
THAT, BUT YOU WERE THERE TO
REPORT ON THE WEATHER, OR THE
TRAFFIC CONDITIONS, THINGS ARE
HAPPENING IN LOCAL COMMUNITY S.
TALK ABOUT THAT, WHY IS IT SO
IMPORTANT TO GO OUT THERE AND DO
THAT KIND OF REPORTING THAT YOU
DO THAT FOUND YOURSELF IN THE
SITUATION YOU WERE IN THE OTHER
DAY?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I GO OUT THERE SO YOU DON'T HAVE
TO.
I GO OUT THERE TO ALERT YOU AS
TO WHAT'S GOING ON.
AT THAT MOMENT, NOTHING WAS
GOING ON WITH THE WEATHER.
I FIGURED I COULD KIND OF JUST
TALK ABOUT THE WATER MAIN BREAK
SINCE THAT MOST LIKELY HAPPENED
DUE TO THE TEMPERATURES SHIFTING
A BIT.
THAT'S JUST SOMETHING WE KIND OF
SEE WITH COLDER TEMPS.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
GET OUT THERE.
I DO HOPE THAT PEOPLE KIND OF
TAKE AWAY THAT THOUSANDS OF
JOURNALISTS ARE OUT THERE DOING
EVERYTHING, ONE MAN BAND, ONE
WOMAN BANDING IT, WE'RE KIND OF
JUST REPORTING, WRITING,
EDITING, SHOOTING VIDEO ALL ON
OUR OWN, AND I AM GRATEFUL THAT
I HAD THAT OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE
IT'S REALLY HELPED ME BECOME A
BETTER JOURNALIST, I BELIEVE,
AND IN THAT MOMENT, I HAD A LOT
OF EMERGENCY LIGHTS BEHIND ME.
MY NEWS VEHICLE WAS PARKED ABOUT
TEN FEET IN FRONT OF ME, AND I
WASN'T ON THE ROAD.
I WAS NEXT TO THE ROAD, BUT I
WAS IN THE AN APARTMENT COMPLEX
ENTRANCE EXIT AREA RIGHT AT THE
BOTTOM OF THIS PRETTY STEEP
HILL.
IT IS WEST VIRGINIA.
BUT AT THAT POINT I FELT REALLY
SAFE.
MY BOSS ALWAYS PREACHED TO ME IF
YOU DON'T FEEL SAFE, DON'T DO
IT.
HAD I FELT IN ANY TAPE OF DANGER
I WOULD HAVE LEFT.
I'M GLAD PEOPLE ARE TALKING
ABOUT SAFETY AND HAVING THAT
CONVERSATION, I THINK IT NEEDS
TO BE HAD, BUT FOR ME PERSONALLY
I DID NOT FEEL UNSAFE IN THAT
SITUATION.
>> YOU THOUGHT THIS WAS MORE OF
A FREAK ACCIDENT THAN, YOU KNOW,
LOCAL REPORTERS PUTTING
THEMSELVES IN AN UNSAFE
SITUATION UNNECESSARILY.
AND I HAVE TO THINK THAT YOU
HEARD FROM PEOPLE ALL OVER THE
PLACE, FRIENDS YOU HAVEN'T HEARD
FROM IN A LONG TIME,
RELATIVES
AND SO ON, WHAT'S THAT
EXPERIENCE BEEN LIKE?
>> IT WAS MY LAST DAY YESTERDAY,
I'M GOING TO START A NEW JOB AT
WTAE IN PITTSBURGH NEXT WEEK, SO
I'M TRYING -- THANK YOU.
I'M TRYING TO KIND OF KEEP MY
LIFE MOVING IN THE SENSE OF
LITERALLY PACKING UP MY LIFE AND
MOVING, SO IT'S BEEN KIND OF A
LOT AND A LITTLE OVERWHELMING,
BUT I REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE
KIND WORDS.
PEOPLE ARE REALLY, REALLY VERY
SWEET, AND I DEFINITELY WANT TO
MAKE SURE I DO SAY TOO MY ANCHOR
OBVIOUSLY COULDN'T SEE WHAT
HAPPENED IN THAT SHOT.
HIS EYES WERE ON THE CAMERA.
HIS CONFUSION CAME THAT HE
DIDN'T SEE ME IN THE FRAME, YOU
KNOW, AFTER IT HAD HAPPENED.
HE WAS KIND OF, OKAY, YOU GOT
HIT BY A CAR?
OKAY, BUT YOU'RE UP, SO WHERE
DID THE CAR HIT YOU.
>> FOR THE RECORD, HE WAS BEING
A GOOD GUY.
HE'S A GOOD GUY.
>> HE REALLY IS.
HE'S A GREAT GUY.
HE'S LIKE A DAD TO ME.
HE HAS CHECKED ON